[Music]
so the introduction of Bucky Barnes the
Winter Soldier in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is a pretty big thing not
necessarily because of Bucky Barnes
being the Winter Soldier but because of
the ramifications that this can have
especially when you look further down
the line with the roles at the Winter
Soldier plays with regards to the Marvel
Universe this is really an ominous thing
and this ominous more so for Captain
America than it is for anybody else in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so before
we get too far into this backstory I do
want to say that this portion of the
video may contain spoilers so proceed at
your own risk
so Bucky Barnes first appears alongside
Captain America and Captain America
comics issue number one in 1941 and like
Captain America Bucky Barnes is a
creation of Joe Simon and Jack Kirby and
is designed to be a propaganda piece but
where Captain America is a propaganda
piece that's really geared towards
adults Bucky Barnes is geared towards
children and is designed to spur support
for world war ii among children who in
turn will influence their parents Bucky
Barnes remains a mainstay in Captain
America comics until issue number 66 and
what I'd like you guys to take
particular note of is that over the
course of these sixty-six issues where
Bucky Barnes in Captain America
initially start off fighting Nazis Nazi
creations Nazi soldiers and Adolf Hitler
there comes a point where they
transition to fighting crime here in the
United States and this is something that
I'd like to keep in the back of your
head
because this will become important later
on when we learn about the backstory of
both Bucky Barnes and Captain America
with issue number 66 of the Captain
America comics Bucky Barnes is severely
injured by a gunshot and is replaced by
Captain America's girlfriend Betsy Ross
who undertakes the mantle of the golden
girl now Bucky Barnes eventually returns
in Captain America comics issues number
76 77 and 78 although he and Captain
America are now communist fighters and
this is during the dawn of the Cold War
era now after issue number 78 the
Captain America comics are canceled and
we do not see Bucky Barnes reappear
outside of a flashback capacity until
2004 or 2005 now when I say a flashback
capacity what I mean is that there are a
few times that Bucky Barnes reappears
the most notable is during the Avengers
issue number 4 which was released in
1964 and at this time Jack Kirby and
Stan Lee are at the helm with regards to
writing and creating characters in
Marvel Comics when Captain America is
rediscovered in the Avengers issue
number four we get the backstory about
what happened with regards to Captain
America after his disappearance after
World War two and what we learn is that
Captain America and Bucky Barnes were
attempting to stop a drone plane that
had been used by a villain named Baron
Zemo for his own ends at the protests of
Captain America Bucky Barnes boards the
drone plane but the drone plane explodes
very soon after and Bucky Barnes is
presumed to have been dead now there are
other instances where Bucky Barnes
reappears and flashbacks but these are
not considered to be official due to the
backstory that was given to us by Ed
Brubaker in 2004-2005 and especially
with the release of Bucky Barnes life
story in 2011 I believe Bucky Barnes
reappears for the most part in Captain
America vol 5 issue number 1 and this
starts a storyline called out of time
and at the beginning of this storyline
the villain red skull is meeting with an
individual named Alexander Lucan who is
a former KGB general who has fallen out
of favor or the
Alisha's become disillusioned with the
russian government after the fall of the
Soviet empire and Alexander Lucan is
selling various arms and armament to the
Red Skull and over the course of their
meeting the Red Skull comes across a
stasis tank of sorts that is housing an
individual now this individual seems to
be of significance to the Red Skull but
we don't know why and the Red Skull
offers to purchase this individual
Alexander Lucan indicates that he will
give the individual to the Red Skull but
only under the condition that the Red
Skull is willing to trade the Cosmic
Cube at this point the Red Skull does
not have the Cosmic Cube but the Red
Skull states that even if he did he
would not trade it for this individual
because the Cosmic Cube possesses
abilities that would transcend anything
this individual is capable of hmm five
years after the meeting the Red Skull is
in possession of the Cosmic Cube and
after a short phone call with Alexander
Lucan is promptly assassinated at this
point an unknown assailant takes the
body I'm sorry takes the Cosmic Cube
from the dead grip of the Red Skull and
has a conversation with Alexander
lúthien indicating that he is operating
under the orders of Alexander Lucan and
takes the Cosmic Cube back to Alexander
Lucan from this point moving forward the
cause of the comic turns into a sort of
whodunit mystery and Captain America in
addition to the niece of Peggy Carter
Sharon Carter and Nick Fury sort of go
on this quest to find out one who this
individual is and to why there are
several bombs that have been planted at
different locations throughout
Philadelphia because at this point there
have been several times in which these
bombs have been located and disarmed
ultimately we find out that the purpose
of these bombs is to use their
destruction to empower the Cosmic Cube
for whatever in its possessor chooses to
use it for and in issue number six we
get a full-on view of Bucky Barnes now
it's important to note that this is a
very pivotal panel in comic books
because this indicates the very first
time that we will see Bucky Barnes
return to comic books outside of a
flashback capacity since 1948 which was
the last issue of the Captain America
comics with issue number 78 I believe
Bucky Barnes is revealed to be the
her soldier and prior to this we had
learned some backstory we had learned
some some information from both Nick
Fury and the questionable memories of
Captain America from Nick Fury we
learned that after World War two and
towards the beginning of the Cold War
the Russians had been using an
individual known only as the Winter
Soldier and the Winter Soldier was
considered to be a myth by most because
no one had really ever seen him before
and Nick Fury has in his possession a
total of about ten photos basically and
these photos are not necessarily
concrete but they lead him to believe
that it is Bucky Barnes the information
that we get is that this Winter Soldier
had operated on behalf of the Russian
government to implement a series of
assassinations campaigns and whatnot to
further the goals of the Russian
government during the Cold War and what
happens is that the the government will
freeze they will put Bucky Barnes in a
state of suspended animation
and only release him when he's needed
for a particular goal when the goal is
complete he will be refrozen again and
this is the reason why over the course
of 50 years or so Bucky Barnes has only
aged about 10 years roughly what we also
learned from Captain America's memories
are a series of events and we learn
through the stories that are being told
that Bucky Barnes was not necessarily
what we were led to believe in the early
versions and the flashback of Captain
America's history in the Avengers issue
number four from 1964
we learned that Bucky Barnes became the
sidekick because he had stumbled into
the tent where Steve Rogers was changing
into his Captain America uniform and
agreed to keep Captain America's secret
but only under the condition that
Captain America took him on as a
sidekick this backstory was retconned
that is to admit that is to say that it
was altered by Ed Brubaker and the new
back story was that Bucky Barnes was a
child who had some anger issues some
violent issues of course he was the son
of a military official who had been
killed in an accident on a military base
and as a result he really kind of became
the unofficial mascot for the military
base however he engaged in some very
seedy kind of
actions he would smuggle and things that
people weren't supposed to have on
military bases he would constantly get
into fights and skirmishes and so he was
sent overseas to train with a British
SAS among other military forces to make
him a very formidable soldier the
training lasted about two months and
buggy barns returned and was made into
the partner of Captain America but where
Bucky Barnes is initially perceived in
the Captain America comics to be the
sort of benign and good-natured sidekick
we learned that there is a much darker
side to Bucky Barnes role as the
sidekick of Captain America and that his
role is to do the things that Captain
America can't to assassinate to
infiltrate to inflict harm on
individuals to gain information where
Captain America would not normally take
this role over the course of the
remainder of the out-of-time comics and
the Winter Soldier books we learned that
Captain America eventually comes across
the Cosmic Cube and with the assistance
of the Cosmic Cube Bucky Barnes memories
are restored eventually Bucky Barnes
succumbs to the depression and to the
overwhelming guilt of his previous
actions and kind of goes into hiding but
eventually returns later on to take on
the mantle of Captain America once
Captain America is killed by
assassination over the course of these
comics we also learn the actual
backstory behind how it was that Bucky
Barnes managed to survive and managed to
become the Winter Soldier and what we
learn is that after the drone plane
explosion the body of Bucky Barnes had
been recovered by the predecessor to
Alexander Lucan Vasily Karpov and the
body was taken back to Russia and Bucky
Barnes was revived Bucky Barnes was
subjected to brainwashing whereby his
memories were altered or eliminated and
he was subjected to the Russian version
of the super soldier program where he
was endowed with enhanced abilities
although not quite on par with Captain
America he was also subjected to a
series of training regimens that
enhanced his physical fighting and
military weapons knowledge which that in
terms put him on par with Captain
America simply in terms of his abilities
in hand-to-hand
that and various martial arts over the
course of time we begin to see the
Winter Soldier being implemented as a
weapon as you previously explained and
thus leads him into becoming one of the
most prominent foes of Captain America
during the Winter Soldier storyline so
much like Captain America Bucky Barnes
does not have any superpowers per se
either as the sidekick of Captain
America nor as the Winter Soldier but
what he does have are a very formidable
set of skills and these are skills that
he has developed over the course of his
training with the British SAS and other
military forces in addition to his
real-world combat experience fighting
alongside Captain America in World War 2
in addition to these combat skills that
he is gained
he also has a set of formidable skills
with regards to his training after being
inducted into the Russian version of the
super soldier program this has also
given him the ability to use his
cybernetic arm for a multitude of
various effects which include firing
electric bolts creating EMPs things of
that nature
so ultimately Bucky Barnes for the most
part is on par with Captain America with
his combat prowess and weapons knowledge
it may even be a little further ahead of
him due to the advantage that is given
to him by his cybernetic arm so I am
aware that there are currently spoilers
out there in terms of the film review
for Captain America the Winter Soldier
but I myself have not read any of these
and I intend to go into the movie fresh
with no idea of what it is is going to
take place and so the speculation may
very well be entirely off however I'm
going through the speculation having no
idea what's going to take place in the
film suffice it to say I do not really
know how it is that Captain America I'm
sorry that Bucky Barnes backstory is
going to be explained in Captain America
the Winter Soldier whether his Baxter
will be explained when he was a child or
whether they will focus simply on the
events that took place after he had
fallen out of the Train into the icy
terrain and
Captain America the First Avenger it may
very well be that at this point he was
discovered by Russians we may or may not
see Vasily Karpov we may or may not see
the Red Skull and Alexander Lucan I
don't really know at this point but I do
think that given the reviews of the film
so far given the popularity from those
who have seen it and the rave reviews
that it's received I think it's going to
be a fantastic film and with Sebastian
Stan returning at the helm to play the
role of Bucky Barnes I do think that as
the Winter Soldier he will be played
adequately and fairly and reasonably on
par with the Winter Soldier as we saw
him in the Captain America comics vol 5
so with that being said I'm going to go
ahead and bring this video to it and
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace